if you [ __ ] take yourself so [ __ ]
serious that you don't see when people
that actually have talent
are doing [ __ ] with it that you are so
insecure that you get mad or upset
you're a [ __ ] idiot damn
damn the one and only how are you man
i'm quite well how are you two guys
we're good man we see
all the appearances you do man
everyone's always asking you to explain
things and give advice on things but no
one ever asks you man how are you doing
yeah that's very nicely i appreciate
that i am doing really well man yeah
well you say we're youngsters but you're
46 cody you're 50.
i'm a sprightly 31 actually thank you
very much let's appreciate that great
and great [ __ ] hair wow let's go
really wow okay can i
who would debate that
i will he would he [ __ ] would you
know who he would
[Applause]
how much good [ __ ] is happening one of
the reasons i couldn't wait to like do
this with you guys is like
i'm so ridiculous as a communicator like
i think i'm the greatest fodder for like
laughs and so me and my boys are that
way that's how he is like anybody that
wasn't close to you would all agree that
your hair is the best but your boy can
be like your hair sucks [ __ ] yeah and
that sucks the problem is that's the
only person you believe
is that guy
you're like [ __ ] man i am it does suck
it's receding a little bit god damn it
you know what's funny and i think you
guys know this in the context i think of
what you guys do so well
there's something so special
about like that inner circle that like
the love the razz
the zinging and the hu it's all just one
same
macro like
like all love you know what i mean yeah
definitely now that i'm known enough
that people do [ __ ] about me
hey
i'm humbled
like i'm like this is crazy that i'm
subject matter for talented people and
two if you [ __ ] take yourself so
[ __ ] serious that you don't see when
people that actually have talent
are doing [ __ ] with it that you are so
insecure
that you get mad or upset you're a
[ __ ] idiot
damn
damn it's very easy for me to see who is
talented and being creative
versus does somebody have malicious
intent and wants to hurt somebody it's
just i don't know for me it comes very
natural i'm not even talking about me
i'm just like talking like when you
watch [ __ ] i'm like that's creativity
and pop culture oh
this person's hurting inside and just
wants to tear this other it's so crystal
clear yeah yeah so for me
no i mean i think you guys are
genuinely talented and i'm like
flattered for any time i'm in your
[ __ ] mouth damn that means a lot
honestly so you've seen demented garyvee
then yes okay good we wanted to ask you
what you thought
i sometimes want to be demented gary
yeah
my mom did too good job
and making me i have a [ __ ] funny
communication style that out of context
i think it's real funny real quick i
think i think that yeah like
like saying stuff like i want to rip my
arms off and what are you saying that oh
you said like kill your family or
something no no no
before we go down this road gary can you
just can you just
make my year and say
picture swallowing a bag of nails can
you just say that line mayonnaise of
nails i need you to picture yourself
swallowing a bag of nails
oh you're a legend you're a [ __ ]
legend those are like me trying to like
shake somebody totally
yeah
like they gotta be on their report card
or their friend got a total
bro and this is where tick tock as a
format [ __ ] me i was like oh [ __ ]
people can stitch [ __ ]
edit it the way they want to yeah now
you have people armless bleeding out on
tock and they're like gary told me to do
it and now gary's on the other side like
i didn't tell you to do it i was just
using a metaphor man i don't really have
a different gear
i'm different contextually if we were
sitting down for an hour and you're like
hey we want to really blow this business
out yeah like how do you think about
what like you'd be like whoa that's a
different gary than we had on the
podcast because i go into like
operations mode but in general like
talking
differently has really been who i've
been my whole life mainly because i
failed every class and then not well
read i had to almost make up my own
language we dm'd on october 11th when i
asked you to do this so we arranged this
and we said okay let's make it happen
hit me on the email whatever and then
october 15th you sent me a video of
yourself it was a tick tock that you did
saying that uh it was basically saying
like you lose out on opportunities by
making fun of them or being negative and
then you said had to do it and i just
want to know do you do you hate me oh i
oh i'm sorry i sent that to like 25
people that i had just talked to on dm i
meant had to do it to society that
wasn't just to you
i thought it was i thought it was ultra
targeted at me
because you had seen like
you know something that we did and you
were like you know what he actually
needs to know this worst advice you've
ever given what is it do you think as
gary vee on stage because i'm talking to
masses i think candor is a strength of
mine i like want to go to the punch line
as an executive because i've been
building businesses my whole life i
actually really struggled with candor i
didn't i don't like confrontation and i
always thought that i could [ __ ]
figure it out i knew that i didn't value
the money enough and so early in my
career when my best friend joined i was
like look if someone sucks you don't
tell them you try to manage around it
and build them up and get them there and
in hindsight it was bad advice i would
i'd be like cody you're great like cody
great hair day cody good [ __ ] and then
out of nowhere on tuesday i'd be like yo
cody got five minutes so cody listen
we're gonna have to let you go what the
[ __ ]
and and and he was like you said my hair
was awesome on friday i'm like yeah but
you know like and and i put this concept
of kind candor into my head i'm like
look i can tell somebody they're really
not good at their job but i can unscare
them by being aggressive about
contextualizing it and communicating
it's really helped me how long have you
been filming yourself doing everything
you were literally literally going to
have a conversation in 41 years
with one of your grandkids around this
exact video right now and that is like
[ __ ] wild yeah both my grandfathers
died before i got to meet them and my
parents who i adore always spit so much
like emotional game to me of like man
you do this just like my dad did like
you know they both lost their dads yeah
and it [ __ ] i think just weighed on
me and at some level i you know it kind
of started with like you know what i
have [ __ ] to say
i'm interested in this
i'm gonna put this on wax aka video and
like it'll be cool like if god forbid
something atrocious happens to me or
even if not it'll be like fun to be like
chilling and like the like the grandkid
runs in and be like no was cody's hair
that nice i was like
it's really [ __ ] rad that you guys
have this and you're gonna chop it up
with people in the future so i like
putting it on it's like just having
photos right like my family didn't have
a lot of photos because in russia he
didn't do that [ __ ] and so like i just
lost all this family heritage i kind of
liked that my life is filmed out and i
also like being right and wrong i love
the merit of the game like i love the
game so much like it's fun to be like oh
[ __ ] i was right about like i secretly
like wonder like man if nfps don't win
i'm gonna have unlimited film to make
fun of myself
if someone is down bad and they needed
to steal what would you tell them to
steal whatever was most stealable
okay
right i mean like
like like like if you work at tar like
if you work at my dad's wine store
like and you're in stocking shelves like
steal the expensive wine okay okay like
if you work at vayner like oh see which
offices are open in the executive's room
and take the most expensive like listen
employees are you enjoying this [ __ ]
the restaurant
the nft restaurant
yeah are we are we good to come through
well if we don't have an nf if we don't
have the
the membership can we just slide through
the back door or something like that
i mean if you put if you want to put on
if you want to punch in and work
[Laughter]
you can go through the back to the
employee entrance
i got i got good news for you guys when
you guys come to new york and q1 early
next year
i've got a couple
of seats that are my table thing i it
would be a genuine pleasure
oh hell yeah have dinner with you guys
and chop it up and get to know each
other better and we will do it in fly
fish club i would love i honestly would
love that yeah
it's the same i would i would love to
are you guys into wine i know a little
bit about gin
no [ __ ] it's funny i've been thinking a
lot more about gin because jyn hasn't
popped insane yet and so that's like the
white space you know that's exactly
that's exactly what i was thinking
yeah literally took the words out of my
mouth
[Music]